[Music]
before we go with some final thoughts
for the last four years we have heard
that donald trump is an autocrat who
wants absolute authority an ego maniacal
narcissist who wants to tear up the
constitution
ignore congress do whatever he wants to
enact his rules and policies but in
reality
he didn't do any of those things that
he's been accused of what proof do i
have let's look at it
he wanted to build the wall when
congress would not well he tried to get
it done but he's not done with it yet
when anarchy raged in major cities from
d.c to seattle to portland to new york
he called for law and order he
threatened to bring in troops to quell
the unrest but for the most part he
didn't
when it came to the pandemic president
power monger empowered the states
with ppe he backed him up with
ventilators commissioned a vaccine
delivered
and let the governors distribute it the
way they would are those the actions of
an absolute monarch or a democratic
president bent on
decentralized authority i kind of
thought that's the way our system worked
well in comes joe biden he's the captain
now he's in the captain's chair now and
he's about to give us a
taste of pure centralized washington
rule just look at the executive orders
we've been
dished with the last few days a federal
decree to wear mass
we already were wearing them a mandate
to open schools new federal guidelines
to open businesses
did trump want business and schools open
i think so but didn't he pretend
he did not pretend that he knew what
your neighborhood needed what your mayor
wanted
joe does i guess the bottom
administration now enacting widespread
use of the defense production act
which means your business could be their
business next anytime
anywhere on their doing well were you
not already doing
everything you could to help out with
this pandemic the answer is yes so if
i'm a mayor if i'm a governor
i've spent the last 10 months calling my
own shots now for democrats and some
republicans like larry hogan
you're the best of both worlds you have
the power to be a hero but if you fell
short you could always blame president
trump those days are
over the president who empowered you is
now golfing but the good news for you is
the blame now belongs to
joe president biden has the game started
you have started and you now have the
game ball
you're choosing to take the first and
last shot you are centralizing testing
ppe vaccines reopening schools and
businesses
on your guidelines we're depending on
you to run the plays you've designed to
perfection because
you sidelined us without our input those
governors and mayors they are now
spectators we're all hoping for the best
but i have seen this bureaucratic play
drawn up before on a whiteboard call
rove's whiteboard and it rarely
ends with victory those are my thoughts
but finally a big thank you to johnny's
luncheonette you saw them
with dave portnoy now johnny's was our
team's choice for lunch today
we wanted to show our support for the
small business we introduced you to last
night
struggling like so many across the
countries johnny's is now receiving help
from dave portnoy's bar stool fund
we hope you will consider supporting
your local small business and big
business because this pandemic is not
ending anytime soon
i'll also want to thank you for joining
me all week on prime time this has been
a thrill
this is a great staff a great show maria
is going to do great next week
i hope you all have a great weekend